So, welcome back everyone.
So,
on Monday, Tatsu did an excellent job of
describing a high-level overview of GPUs
and how to think about performance and
all the quirks that come with GPUs.
This lecture is going to be a
continuation of that where we're going
to dive more deeply into the code, write
some Triton kernels,
and as well as do some benchmarking
profiling.
So, just to start,
just to refresh what's going on with
GPUs,
here is a simplified diagram of what a
typical GPU
you know, looks like.
There's memory and then the actual GPU
chip.
And
just to keep in your head
what are the characteristics of a GPU?
So, of course, we're talking about
Nvidia GPUs, but Tatsu also talked about
TPUs and there's AMD and and so on.
But focusing on Nvidia GPUs, we've had
multiple generations from M100s to H100s
to B200s.
And and
in each generation,
you have a GPU, it has a number of
streaming multiprocessors or SMs.
And
the number of SMs is, you know, about
100 between 100 and 200. So, that hasn't
really changed that much.
And then
within individual SM, there's a set of
registers.
So, B200s have 65,000 registers uh for a
total of 256 K per
SM.
And this also hasn't changed that much.
In addition, there's a L1 cache as well
as shared memory. So, remember these are
the same memory, shared memory you can
control L1. Uh you can't. This is per
SM.
And this is like in the same order
ballpark size.
And then there's a L2 cache.
And this is not per SM, this is for the
whole chip.
And this is a bit larger. And then
finally, you have a high-bandwidth
memory HBM, which is large. And you see
that this is the number that's actually
going up quite a quite a bit.
Okay.
And then
you can
in addition to size, you can think about
what's happening with the bandwidth. And
essentially, it's
you know, kind of inversely
correlated. So, registers are very fast,
L1 is slightly less fast,
L2
is less fast and high-bandwidth memory
is the slowest. Although 8 terabits
terabytes a second is still, you know,
not not
that slow
in the grand scheme of things.
So, this is the kind of main hierarchy
you should have in your head. Memory,
large memory is slow and far, but big.
And fast memory like registers and L1
resides on SM, it's local and it's fast,
but small. Okay? That's the what the
environment we're dealing with.
Okay, so then how do you program a GPU?
So, the the program model is as follows.
So, there's notions of threads, which
each thread executes a piece of code on
a small part of the data. So, each of
one of these arrows, you can think about
it as a thread. These threads are
organized into thread blocks.
Also known as a concurrent thread arrays
or CTAs. And this is a group of threads.
And then finally, you have you have a
collection of thread blocks, which forms
the grid. So, when you launch a kernel,
you're basically launching a grid of
threads and thread blocks to all
parallel
you know, simultaneously do some you
know, computation.
Okay. So, this is a simplified, there's
some other things that are happening.
For example, there's H100s and B200s
also have thread block clusters, which
are clusters of thread blocks that
enable some amount of
distribution memory. Also, B200s have
tensor memory now for tensor cores,
which is somewhere between the registers
and shared memory.
Some of these things are kind of
invisible to the programmer, but they
are in and
in the hardware.
But we won't worry about them for this
intro lecture.
Okay, so one thing you might ask about
is why do we have thread blocks?
Why can't we just have a grid of threads
and each thread just takes a piece of
data and does something?
And this would be normally fine if all
you want to do is element-wise
operations, which we'll see. For
example, GELU is a activation function
that applies element-wise. And threads
are pretty natural. Each thread
processes one element. So, it's like FI
for I equals you know, ranging over your
data set.
But for operations
that are
involved
communicating with you know, threads
such as softmax or matrix
multiplication,
this view isn't really enough.
And and the reason is that well, it it
could be enough if you were willing to
pay the cost of writing and reading HBM.
Because then you can still have, for
example, in a matrix, we'll see later,
you can just have every element in a
cell, it goes and computes that element
of the matrix.
And it can just read and write HBM. But
as we've noticed,
HBM is very slow, so this would not be a
good strategy.
So, instead, what we should do is use
shared memory.
Which is local to a
SM.
And what the thread block allows you to
think about is a collection of threads
that are all going to access the shared
memory.
So,
um
So, uh consequently, you can think about
a thread block, one of these
thread blocks is being scheduled on one
of these semantic
not semantic streaming multiprocessors
and it does its thing.
And what it's going to do is it's going
to read a bunch of data from HBM and
then process it. Where the processing
might involve communication between you
know, the the threads via the shared
memory and then writes it back out.
Okay?
So, this is kind of a critical piece
that comes up. Later, we'll talk about
tiling and that's the whole kind of game
here.
Okay, in in Triton, in fact, which we'll
see as the primary way that we're going
to write kernels these days, we're going
to think natively in thread blocks.
And you know, I think once you get the
hang thing of hang of thinking in thread
blocks, this makes
a lot of sense and makes your life a lot
easier as we'll see.
Okay, so the programming model is is
fairly
you know, simple, I think. There's
threads, thread blocks, and grids.
Okay, so
where I think things get a bit more you
know, complicated is the interaction
between the programming model and the
hardware.
So, the programming model is actually
very nice. It provides abstraction of
the hardware. You when you you can write
a kernel, you just
all you have to know is that there's a
bunch of thread blocks, you define them,
and then define what computations
each thread
within the block or the thread block has
to do. And those are just like writing
it's like writing Python.
So, that part isn't hard. And in fact,
if you don't care about if you just care
about correctness, that's all you need
to know.
But in practice, the performance is very
sensitive to the hardware.
And so, you need to really deeply
understand the hardware to obtain high
performance. In fact, the whole reason
we're talking about GPUs and kernels is
that you're trying to squeeze out
performance.
So, there's sort of these two levels
here where you're trying to understand
the computation and that is only
a part of the programming model, but you
know, how fast it runs is going to be
strongly dependent on the hardware.
Okay, so I'm going to give you some
examples of why this matters. And some
of this will be review from what Tatsu
you know, talked about, but hopefully
it'll reinforce some of these concepts.
So, I think there will be around five
different examples. And
you know, this is just to give you a
flavor of
the considerations.
So, there's something called warps,
which I didn't talk about. So, in the
very simplified view, warps are not
really part of the this clean picture of
the programming model. You have threads
and thread blocks or
grids.
Technically, you can also
exceed the warps, but you don't you
know, have to when you're just you know,
programming.
So, what is a warp? So, each thread
blocks, remember, is a collection of
threads. But these threads are actually
grouped into warps. And
you know, there's basically 32 threads
per warp. So, for example, if you have
64 threads in a thread block, there's
two warps, the first 32 and the second
32.
And as Tatsu mentioned last time, all
threads within a warp, all of these Ts,
must execute the same instruction in
lockstep on
SM. So, every cycle,
they have to execute exactly the same
instruction. And control divergence
is when
different threads within a warp need to
actually execute different instructions.
For example, if you have branching, if A
um if something then A else B.
And then what happens is that you can
only do the A's in your threads in your
warp, and then you do the B. So this
gets kind of sequentialized.
So this is bad and inefficient, and
that's why branching is
is something you want to generally
avoid.
One thing that's I think really
cool about warps is that a SM actually
is running multiple warps. There's a
warp scheduler, and there's a bunch of
you know resident warps that are
about to to run. Each warp has some you
know
and threads have registers.
And you this SM can switch between them
with
you know zero cost.
Right? This is not true in general like
on a on a CPU, but this way that it's
designed is to hide latency.
So
this is important because one of one of
the warps is for example reading from
HBM, which remember is is very
expensive. Can take like a you know 100
cycles or something. You don't want to
just sit around waiting for that warp to
do nothing. You switch immediately to
another warp where it can actually do
some tensor core operations.
Okay. So so that's one thing to note
about the warp. And another reason why
warp comes
up is this idea of occupancy,
more specifically warp occupancy.
So each thread
just you know the hardware constraint
says that each thread can use at most
255 registers.
Okay?
And so what happens is that the SM has a
fixed number of registers. So the more
registers each thread is using, the
fewer threads you can have. That's just
you know
math. And
that is called
that can reduce your occupancy.
But that's not necessarily bad because
if you have fewer threads,
but each thread is doing more work, that
can actually be good. So you know
occupancy is
something that you can measure, but it's
not necessarily the larger
the better because there are some other
trade-offs here.
In fact an example where
you might want to
you know have fewer threads is this idea
of thread coarsening where let's say you
have a
you know element-wise operation, and
you're going to
you can have one thread just perform
work on one element. Okay? So then you
have a lot of threads. But you can also
say each thread processes multiple
elements like a constant maybe eight. So
that gives you fewer threads, which
makes scheduling and these things
easier, but each thread is doing more
work.
So if your threads are very light, maybe
you want to fatten them up a little bit.
Okay.
So
just as an example of
what might happen here. So suppose you
have a block a thread block with 128
threads in it. And each thread is using
160 registers.
Okay? So there's a hardware constraint.
So the the B200s have a maximum of
registers of 65,000
per
SM.
And it also has a constraint that says
you can't run more than 65 64 warps at a
time.
So then you can can go and do some
simple math to compute how many
what is a you know occupancy here.
So you know number of registers per
thread, this has to be less than 255.
That's fine.
The number of registers that you're
using per block is the number of threads
per block times number of registers per
thread. That's 20,000. That means you
can run at most three blocks on your SM
concurrently.
And then that corresponds to
12 warps.
And because the number of maximum warps
is 64, that means you have a occupancy
of
you know 18%. So you're only using
running 18% of the total number of
you know warps you have. And this is
because you have a lot of register use
per thread.
Okay? So this is an example of where
I guess this is sort of memory is kind
of constraining you in terms of how much
compute you can do.
Okay. Here's another example, something
called bank conflicts. This applies to
shared memory.
So remember shared memory is um
like L1. It's on a SM.
And just the way the hardware works is
that shared memory is divided into 32
banks, each one 4 bytes wide. Okay? So
these are my 32 banks, and this is my
memory
here. Each bank has
many
elements here.
So there's a constraint that says every
you know clock cycle, each bank can only
be accessed by one thread, at most one
thread.
Assuming that's not a location. So for
example, if
you can't access this location and this
location
you know at the same time.
Which means that if you have multiple
threads that are trying to access the
same bank, the accesses have to be
serialized.
And this leads this is called a bank
conflict. In the worst case example,
imagine this were a matrix that was kind
of laid out like this, and you had some
operation where 32 threads, you think
wow this 32 is so great I can massively
parallelize this, and you try to all
access this first column. They're just
going to just wait in line.
And this is a 32-way bank conflict,
which is the worst possible
setting you can be in.
And now you could say well okay, why do
you do that? Just like access rows of
course, but you know this is unavoidable
because for example, if you're doing a
matmul, you have to access rows of one
matrix and columns of the other matrix,
and sometimes you do transposes. So you
can't always just get away with choosing
the order in which you
go down. Um
you know um
you know for element-wise operations
it's fine. You can go in any kind of
order. But if you're doing matmuls, you
can't control like for every matrix
which
row major or column major you're doing.
There's some solutions here, which I
won't get into. Something called
swizzling, which arranges your shared
memory so that when you're going
through, you can kind of avoid bank bank
conflicts.
Okay. So that's you know another you
know consideration. And when you're you
know profiling, you can look at the bank
conflicts. You can look at occupancy,
and you can kind of see
you know what's what's happening.
A final note, which are actually two
more things. So memory coalescing, which
talked to you talked about, so I'll just
really quickly remind people
what this is about. So when you have 32
threads in a warp, and they try to
access HBM,
the memory accesses actually get
combined into a transaction
of 20 to 128 bytes, which are called
cache lines, and it goes and fetches it
all at
at once.
So
imagine you have memory laid out like
this. This is
uh um
wide.
And
you know in the in the best case, which
is called full coalescing,
um
all the threads are accessing the same
cache line. So you have thread one
accessing M00, thread two accessing M01,
and so on. Which means that
you know at all at once you're going to
grab this entire cache line.
Right? And whereas if you
go down the columns, then
um then
you know you're going to fetch a lot of
memory here, which you're not going to
use.
Same for the second row and and so on.
Um And so this is similar to feel
similar to bank conflicts, but it's a
very different constraint. And this is
about shared memory, and this is about
HBM.
Okay?
Okay. So final thing, block occupancy.
So thread blocks are remember scheduled
onto SMs.
But you know we live in a you know
finite
you know logically you can define as
many thread blocks as you want, but
physically on chip you only have a
certain number of SMs. For example, 148.
So if you launch 160 thread blocks, then
you can only schedule 148 of them, and
then you have to wait until they're
done, and then you schedule the 12. But
what happens if you schedule 12 is that
there's a bunch of the SMs are just not
doing anything.
So that's called you know low occupancy
when the last wave of thread blocks gets
fewer
than the total maximum number of
thread blocks.
Okay. So in general, you know maybe it's
a good idea to make the number of thread
blocks divide the the SMs. Um
So
so maybe it's just just to summarize
here.
You know there is a very elegant
programming model where you have a grid
of thread blocks, and the thread blocks
have individual threads in them. And
you know at and in terms of the memory,
HBM is global to everyone. Shared memory
is local to a thread block,
and registers are local to a thread.
But again, all the details of the
hardware, warps, bank conflicts, memory
coalescing, occupancy
really determine you know performance.
So so I think um
you know and and many of these details
are sort of hard to know because you
don't I mean, the profiling tells you
a bunch of information, but you know,
you have to know exactly how many
SMs there are and exactly the sizing of
everything and that's gets
you know, sometimes the scheduler does
something you don't really have control
over what it's doing.
So, it's a lot messier than the the
programming model.
Okay.
I will stop there for questions. Yeah.
Yeah, so quick question. So, can is
there a scenario in which the
kernel can share an SM or like for
example like in the problem we see like
148 SMs and 165 blocks, right? And we
have to like launch in the two different
ways. Is there no way in which a block
can like share an SM?
Yeah, so the question is can a block
you know, share an SM? I think the issue
is is if you're doing things right then
the the
you know, the I guess it depends on the
block. This is if you have a block
that's for example using most of the
tensor cores on the SM then putting
another
you know, block there isn't really going
to you know, speed things up.
I think fundamentally there is this sort
of jagged you know, problem here
of unevenness. The because the blocks
have to stay together. So, you can't
like take this and like spread it out
over here. You can define your
you can I think the thing the thing you
would do is to change your block size.
So, you should change the number of
blocks. So, you don't get this kind of
tail here.
Any other questions?
Okay. So, let's move on. So, that was
hopefully you guys are
you know, getting more comfortable with
GPUs now.
So, now I'm going to talk about
benchmarking and you know, profiling.
I'm not going to actually maybe say
that much in terms of content,
but I do want to emphasize the the
philosophy here
which is here's a recipe for success.
You benchmark and profile your code. You
make changes and you benchmark your
profile your code again.
And and the reason I'm doing
benchmarking and profiling as opposed to
teaching you try and earlier is because
you know, you should always just measure
what's going on
in your code and find figure out what
the bottlenecks are before you start you
know,
writing kernels.
Okay, so
benchmarking
is basically how long things take. And
it gives you just this end-to-end time.
It doesn't tell you where things are you
know, spent,
but nonetheless it's pretty useful
because ultimately that's the thing that
you you care about how long you know,
things are running for.
And it also gives you because it
distills things into one number, you can
see how things are scaling. Let's say
with dimension.
So, there's a you know, nice
tool for benchmarking, but because this
class is language models from scratch,
I'm going to do it from scratch.
But you know, I I think I'm doing it
just to highlight a few
gotchas with
you know, benchmark. So,
let's say we have this um
operation
matrix multiplication.
So, run operation two is this this
wrapper that basically instantiates two
random square matrices of size dimension
by dimension
and then it returns a function to
perform the operation. Okay, so matmul
if you call this basically does the
matmul of those two random matrices.
The matrix random matrices are already
generated it's just like multiplying the
two.
Okay, so how do you benchmark?
So, the naive thing to do is just start
time, run it and then stop time,
but you know, there's a few things. One
is that always remember to do you know,
warm up. I think I mentioned this
you know, on the first on the second
lecture, but I think it's worth
emphasizing.
And this is because if you have some
some things are lazily compiled and you
want to just make sure that that thing
is
that is that time doesn't
factor into because most of the time you
care about
how fast something is because you're
going to run it over and over again. So,
the initial conditions don't really
matter.
And then you often want to time it
multiple times because there is some
variance. The
kind of the proper way to time things
is to use the these CUDA events that
a start event and an end event which you
can kind of call record on, actually do
the computation and then hit this the
end event record.
And then remember to you know,
synchronize to wait for the CUDA threads
to to finish because
everything on the GPU is happening kind
of async and this is a synchronization
barrier.
And then you record the time.
Okay, and then you can do this again
and then again
and then
you know, here we're just taking the
average.
I think you might want to do you know,
if you are being very particular, you
want probably want to
maybe look at the whole distribution the
P95 or or whatever, but we'll just do
the average here.
And then one thing that you can do with
benchmarking is you can
let's say
scale up your your matrices and see how
the time you know, changes and you can
see that in this case matrix
multiplication you know, as expected it
should grow you know, cubically,
but you know, notice that there is this
floor where up until you get up to like
almost 2000 dimensional matrices things
are basically kind of a you know,
constant, right? And this is because as
we've kind of discussed the shapes of
the you know, these
you know, GPUs are built for fairly
large matrix multiplications and if you
have like a 2 by 2
matrix [clears throat] it's going to be
very kind of inefficient.
Okay.
So,
really quickly on profiling
profiling tells you where time is
actually spent. Hopefully all of you are
familiar with profiling and are
doing it. Maybe less obviously profiling
even if you don't care about the time
helps you
figure out what's actually happening
under the hood because especially with
these high-level languages you write
some code and then it runs and you get
some result and sometimes it can be just
like good to understand what's actually
going on.
So, PyTorch has a built-in profiler in
your assignment you're using site which
gives you
more details,
but we're going to skip that for the in
the interest of time.
So,
let's start with just you know, the
if you add two numbers and or sorry two
tensors in in PyTorch.
Again, run operation creates two random
matrices and and applies operation.
So, in profiling I'm warming up and then
I'm just you know, putting this context
and
the profiling context and doing the the
run.
And then
let's look at what the profile looks
like for just A plus B in in PyTorch.
So, if you're not you know,
normally
doing PyTorch you probably don't think
about it. It's like okay, well, these
two tensors just get added. So, what's
actually going on underneath the hood?
Right? So, if you look at
the things that it's it's calling there
is this um
you know, long name kernel at
CUDA functor add.
So, this is basically you know, a kernel
that adds two two you know, tensors and
you know, the the times aren't going to
be that interesting because I'm only
adding. So, that's going to take 100% of
the time.
But this tells you that well, underneath
the hood there is this thing called add.
What about matmul?
So, I'm going to
you know, in PyTorch I'm doing A at B.
Um
Similarly, there is this
you know, long name that describes this
particular matmul you know, kernel.
Um color
F32 F32 64 64 16 and so on.
Notice that if you change the the
dimensions. So, now I'm doing a 128 by
128 matmul. You get actually a different
one. If you look closely that this is 64
64 16. This is 32 32 16.
Okay, so
underneath the hood you know, PyTorch
it looks like you're doing just add, but
underneath the hood there could be all
sorts of things that are you know,
happening.
So, observations.
Here you can see which CUDA kernels are
actually being called. These are
generally the ones that are have the
long names and different CUDA kernels
are invoked depending on
the you know, tensor dimensions.
The name actually tells you something
about the implementation as well. So,
this name So, CUTLASS is the NVIDIA CUDA
library for
linear algebra. SM100 corresponds to the
Blackwall you know, architecture. So,
this is a kernel that's specifically
designed for Blackwall.
This is FP 32 and then 64 64 16 is the
shape
of the tile, which we're going to talk
about later when we talk about tiling in
the context of matmuls.
Okay.
So, uhm
last benchmarking profiling, just
remember to to do it. Uhm I think we
make you do it on the assignment, so you
have no choice.
Uhm okay.
So, let's apply this uhm
to another example here on the GELU.
So, uhm
So, remember the GELU activation uh you
know function is uhm this this function,
which is a typical non-linearity that's
used. Often it's approximated with this
uhm uh
you know tanh approximation, which is uh
more compute-friendly.
Okay. So, uhm so naively, uhm if you
implement the the GELU, you can do it in
PyTorch uhm just like this.
So, you take a tensor, you just you know
take this equation and you just put it
into PyTorch, okay?
Uhm that's fine.
And you get some number.
Uhm PyTorch also has a built-in uhm
you know if you call
NN functional GELU, uhm you can get that
version as well.
So, uhm and you can check that they're
they're the same. You can run uhm the
the two uh
you know GELU versions and make sure
that the answer is the the same for a
random input.
Uhm there's also something that uhm
you know people probably some have
discovered. It's it's a if you you know
haven't encountered this, this is a
important thing to know, is that you can
take any PyTorch function, you call
torch.compile it on it and it generates
another uh you know function
uhm and it does the same thing.
Uhm okay. So,
we have three uhm horses in this race.
We have the naive uhm implementation.
We have the built-in implementation. We
have the compiled implementation. So,
let's we can benchmark them. Naive takes
uh three
uhm
uh I guess this is
3.75. Built-in is much faster and uhm
compiled is is much faster as well, but
not maybe as quite as
fast as built-in.
Okay. So,
so what's what's happening here? Like
why are why are these things you know
different?
They you know all compute the same
answer, but they have wildly different
performance you know characteristics.
And so, here we can pull up the profiler
and see what's actually going on
underneath the hood. So, if you look at
the naive
uhm GELU here, uhm and just do a
profile, uhm this something's wrong with
this view, so I'm going to go to uhm
this. So, you see that
uhm the profiler shows
uhm you know how time is being spent.
There's a bunch of different kernels on
this binary functor, unary,
uh add,
uhm a tanh is a is a you know kernel
here. And this corresponds to the fact
that in PyTorch, when we write the
PyTorch expression, you look at the
computation graph and each you know
primitive in the computation graph is
actually realizing a kernel.
Right?
And the reason this is slow is that you
know when you launch a kernel,
you know the the kernel has to read from
HBM, pull it all the way over to your
SM, do the computation, and write it
back. And then the next kernel picks it
up from HBM,
you know, and then writes it back and so
on and so forth. So, you're doing a lot
of reads and writes back and and writes
back and forth because between kernel
invocations,
you know, things have to go back to you
know HBM.
>> [clears throat]
[snorts]
>> So,
and if you look at what the built-in is
doing, this is actually not that
interesting. There's this uh GELU CUDA
kernel implementation, which is a single
kernel that just implements the GELU.
And so, why does this exist? Well, well,
because you know, people use GELU, so
someone wrote a kernel for it and put it
in the standard library. Uhm I mean,
this is how
you know, there's no nothing magical.
So, com- compilation is really
interesting here. I'm not going to say
too much about uhm how it works, but
the is is really I think uhm a
fascinating
uhm you know topic where you can take a
a naive implementation,
which you know remember in PyTorch it
has a computation graph, and run a
compiler, which basically
if you look at what's underneath the
hood, it's just a single kernel.
And this is because it's it's figured
out to
uhm uh you know, look at the computation
graph and essentially write that kernel
in
uhm in Triton. So, you can see that this
is actually a Triton kernel.
Okay. So, naive implementation multiple
kernels requires multiple reads and
writes to and from HBM. There's no uh
you know kernel fusion here.
Uhm this is uh slow. The built-in and
compiled version, there's one kernel.
The basically all the operation in the
GELU have been fused together into one
kernel. So, you read from HBM once, you
write to HBM once per you know element.
Uhm and you see that the compiled kernel
is a you know is a Triton kernel.
Okay. So, that maybe is a good segue to
talk about uh what this Triton thing is
all about. Yeah. So, what you know what
is
kernel is this the built-in? Is it also
in
the indices go straight out of CUDA and
So, I don't let's see. I mean, I guess
this says CUDA kernel implementation, so
I imagine someone wrote it in CUDA.
Okay. Any other questions?
Yeah.
Why is
why is Triton kernel
faster than this one?
Uh is CUDA kernel
What uh
So, why is a Triton kernel faster? So, a
Triton kernel is actually not faster in
this
uh case. Oh, sorry.
The the the compiled kernel is the
is one Triton kernel and this is slower
than the built-in. Yeah.
I think last year when I did this, it
was actually closer. Uhm
or
but you know, these things change and
it's very hardware-dependent and you
know, I think none of this is like
terribly optimized. This is just giving
you a the general idea here.
Okay. So, let's uh write some uh Triton
kernels.
Uhm
So, remember our
uh programming model. You have a bunch
of threads organized by thread groups by
thread blocks and there's a grid of
thread blocks.
Okay. And uhm if you were to you know,
write in CUDA, which was originally
developed by NVIDIA and that's been for
years the thing that you do when you
write kernels,
uhm the mental model is what does each
thread do? So, you write a bit piece of
code, which essentially has some ID that
that identifies which thread you're
talking about and it just like executes
the code.
So, the nice thing about this is that
it's very closely related to what is
actually
uhm happening underneath the hood. Uhm
and it's uh you know, fine-grained gives
you fine-grained control,
uhm but you know, there's cons here,
which is that remember all these threads
uhm
uhm are in a thread block
you know, some operations require them
to communicate. So, what has to happen
is that they have to synchronize and uhm
like they read from HBM all at once and
they have to synchronize and do the
computation and then
or uhm and you have to basically do that
you know bookkeeping.
So, if you were doing all element-wise
operations, you know,
this CUDA is just fine. It doesn't
really
uh matter, but as you get more complex
operations, then Triton provides uh some
value uhm
uh of the abstraction. So, Triton
developed by was developed by OpenAI. I
think by now it's been pretty you know
standard. You basically specify what
each thread block you know does.
Uhm generally it's powerful enough,
especially for you know, this class and
you're getting started. If you really go
and want to exploit every single new
feature of the latest hardware, you
know, it might not give you the full
flexibility, but you know, uhm
you know, let's not worry about that.
And the conceptual framework to think
about in Triton is that you're think
about what does a block do?
A block is going to load data into
shared memory, operate it on, and write
it back to you know global memory.
So, in some sense, these blocks are
intermediate point between
uhm thinking about what individual
elements are doing, as well as thinking
about the general operation. And so, in
PyTorch, you basically define these huge
matrices and you say multiply them
together and that's the sort of the
atomic operation and a lot of what
you're thinking about is how do I get
things into big matmuls,
right? And at the at some level, Triton
is sort of
uh you know, hybrid between that and you
know, the individual elements.
As we'll see.
Okay, so let's start with a the value
example here.
Um
So, let's define a 8,000 dimensional
vector and start writing some Triton.
Okay, so
um
So, Triton is basically going to be you
know, you write you know, Python. How
many of you have you have written Triton
before?
Just as a show of hands. Okay. Okay, so
hopefully this I'll try to not that
many, so which is
good because then you won't be bored.
Um okay, so
you know, so this is normal
this is normal PyTorch, right? There's
no Triton here,
but I'm just preparing.
And so what I'm going to do is
I take this tensor
and I'm going to allocate an output
you know, tensor.
Okay? Because in Triton we're not
thinking functionally anymore, we're
just thinking about moving you have to
explicitly read and write. So, there's
no like returning value. So, I'm going
to allocate the output tensor which I'm
going to the kernel is going to write
to.
Um and then
so this tensor is can be you know,
arbitrarily big, right?
And I can't generally fit this all into
one SM because
you know, it's just it's just too big.
Um so, I need to break it up into
blocks.
So, what I'm going to do is you can
think about
um
you know, this this X is being this
array.
I'm going to chop it up into blocks, so
the total number of elements is 8,000.
I'm just going to set the block size to
1024 you know, for now.
And and then I have eight blocks.
Okay.
Um so,
then I'm going to
use this sort of weird syntax to call
the the kernel. Um so, Triton value
kernel
this basically in in brackets tells me
the
essentially the shape of the grid.
So, basically this says the grid has num
blocks
you know, blocks.
Um and I'm going to for every one of
these blocks invoke
this function Triton value kernel which
I'll talk about in a bit. I'm going to
pass in an X, Y,
num elements and the block size.
Okay?
All right, so unfortunately I'm not
going to be able to trace through this,
so I'll just show you that what the code
looks like
um here.
So,
let me get rid of that.
Okay, so this is
probably the kind of the simplest kernel
you can imagine. So,
when you
are looking at the Triton value kernel.
Now, this is um
you know, before we had X and Y. So, now
these are pointers, right? You can think
about these are just like
integers, they're addresses.
Um so, you have to get comfortable with
that. Um and then we have the number of
elements and the block size
which are basically passed um
and
uh
actually passed in from here.
Okay, so the way to think about is that
for every block
we're going to have this function being
you know, called.
And um
and what happens is the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to wake up this
this you know, block wakes up and say
who am I? Um well, the program ID is is
basically the PID is basically
identifying the block. So, PID would be
zero for this block one, two and three
here.
Okay, so now I have to figure out what
data I'm going to operate on.
So, that's PID times block size.
So, this is the this is the offset into
X pointer.
So,
if PID is zero, then start is zero. If
PID is one, then start is block size. If
PID is two, then it's two times block
size and so on.
Okay?
So, now I'm going to
figure out the the span I'm operating
on. So, offsets is start plus
this is the you know, the Triton
um you know, library
A range zero block size which gives
conceptually gives you the integers zero
through block size minus one.
So, offsets is going to be
essentially you know,
for let's say block one, it's going to
be block size, block size plus one all
the way to blocks two times block size
minus
one.
Okay, so um
you know, in this case num elements
divides block block size, but in general
that's not the the case. So, you'll
often see in Triton code there's this
masking which says well, sometimes if
the let's say the tensor only goes up to
here, then I'm going to form a a mask
which is
going to be true up until that point and
false after that point.
And for blocks that are don't are not
the final block, it's going to be just
all ones.
Okay, so now I've done the the setup.
What I do is I read
and this is basically pointer
arithmetic. So, X pointer remember is
the integer that specifies the memory
location of where X is. I'm going to add
offsets to that which gives me the
the first block size number of elements
there.
Um you know, according to the mask if
I'm masked out and I don't you know, I
don't I don't read it.
Um and then now I I think you know, you
can just think about this as a you know,
a vector.
Um and then you do your normal
computation.
And and then you get you know, Y.
And Y is the same size as X and then you
do TL store
Y pointer plus offsets on Y and and the
mask.
Okay? So, this load loads from HBM
does some stuff and then it writes back
to HBM.
Okay, I'm going to stop there
um and take any questions about this
first
kind of Triton kernel.
Uh yeah.
Yeah, so the difference is what is the
difference between CUDA? And that it's
for this element wise it looks
pretty much the same, right? And in in
fact, CUDA's even I think simpler
because it really is element wise. You
wake up and you I identify the thread
and then you just operate on that
element. Um now, the only thing here is
that it's sort of like the vectorized
version where you
you have a block and you operate on that
block.
Um later we'll see that
operating on blocks is is doing more
than if you do more something more than
element wise, then CUDA's going to be a
lot more annoying to work with. Uh
there's a bunch of questions. Yeah, back
there.
So, how is this related to if you want
to use the tensor units?
Um so, I'll later show you what this
code actually compiles down into and
maybe we'll I'll get back to that.
But the short answer is that you don't
control that. Like the hardware figures
out what where to put things.
Yeah. Can you actually walk through
what's happening at the level
from HBM to shared to register? What's
like the step-by-step where things are
actually going?
Yeah, so the question is what is
actually happening when this
uh um the same end is executed. Um
you know, so the the short version is
that this is in some sense a a lie,
right? It's not like the GPU
actually uh calls the
you know, the Triton library on the GPU
and it's like actually executing this
code. This is basically for our
consumption to you know, specify the
computation. The compiler takes this as
we'll see later and writes it into
something called PTX and then it will
actually do the
you know, the work.
But conceptually like conceptually um so
so that's mechanically what's happening
which I'll get to later. Um
if you're asking about the conceptual
question um
the way to think about this is that um
you know, this
ish
X pointer is uh
you know, a memory location in in HBM.
And this basically specifies a range of
memory locations and load takes those
memory locations and returns the data
associated with them.
And it gets you know, here I have a
local variable I called X.
In practice this is going to be
generally you know, a register or shared
memory. Actually, you know, you don't
actually
you know, Triton kind of figures out
what to what to do there.
Um the thread level
and this is like so when this is
invoked, it's not really clear like did
it did I did I line up what is going to
be in shared and going to be at the
register level beforehand or is it
happening now? Like, which is like way
late. And so, that's just we're all all
the threads are sitting
idle to get
uh memory to flush in.
Um
execute so that it's not we're not
sitting there twiddling our thumbs just
waiting for data to come in from HBM.
Yeah, yeah. So, the question is like,
when does this actually get executed?
Doesn't this like block? Um let me try
to come back to this question while I
show you the PTX and maybe hopefully
it'll provide a bit more context on
what's happening.
Okay, any other questions?
Okay, so this is a all the kernels are
going to look something like this. So, I
I do want to make sure people understand
um
you know, the just the general form,
which is that you have generally your
inputs, your outputs, you wake up, you
figure out uh which index you're going
to look at, you read, you do some stuff,
and then you write to HBM.
Okay.
Um
So,
Okay, so let's talk about PTX briefly.
Um
So, let's see, how does this work? Does
this link work?
Okay.
Um so,
um when you
you know, uh write Triton,
the compiler generates uh PTX code,
which is this intermediate assembly
language for new GPUs.
Um
You know, I am obviously not going to go
through all this, but just to give you
the the flavor of what this uh you know,
um you know, looks like.
Um let me actually start with obser-
observation. So, a few things. So,
um
you know, this is now what a thread is
actually doing.
Um not a a thread block because that's
been kind of compiled, you know, away.
Um
And so, um
you know, if you look at
um a few few notes here. So, this LD
global
is is basically saying load from
um HBM
into some registers, and the registers
are denoted as as like the R R are
integer registers, FR you know, floating
point, you know, registers.
Um and then you have statements like,
you know, move zero into R5, move zero
into R6, and so on.
Um and then you have multiplication,
you're going to multiply this register
by this, you know, constant, and then um
put it in you know, this.
So, this code gets executed, and at the
bottom you should see
um you know, global uh store. So, this
is writing back into the HBM.
So, this gets executed. This is actually
the code that uh gets executed on, you
know, a thread.
Um
you know, and Triton is basically a you
know, a layer above you know, above
that.
Um
one other thing to notice is that, you
know, you see all these you know, kind
of blocks, and what's going on there.
And what's going on there is what you
know, I'm alluding to thread coarsening,
which is that this is one thread, but
rather than processing a single element,
it's actually processing eight uh
elements. So, the compiler decided that,
well, actually this thread is pretty
lightweight, it doesn't do that much, so
let's just try to thicken it up a little
bit.
Um so,
you know, looking at PTX can give you
some sort of appreciation for um you
know, what's what's going on underneath
the hood.
Yeah. So, it makes this for each
individual So, all of these are
So, probably
the same one for the whole thing.
Uh so, the question is, does it make
this for each thread? So, this is
compiled uh you know, once, and it's the
same piece of code that each thread
runs.
And the way that the thread uh
distinguishes itself is that this piece
of code gets passed
um
basically the you know, the thread
you know, ID.
Uh so, here the CTA.x
is the block index, and TID.x is the
thread index. So, um this basically if
this piece of code is running, this
tells you which block I'm um in.
And uh T- TID.x tells you which thread
inside that block I'm in.
Okay.
Okay. Um
any other questions? And I'm trying to
figure out a
Okay.
Okay, so that's a
generally a flavor of you know, your
first Triton kernel kernel um
load from HBM, compute, write back to
HBM, and
um
and
and then we saw the PTX, which is like
kind of the the grungy what actually
happens underneath the the hood. There's
still a lot of things that are not
specified in the PTX. Like, for example,
which SMs things are operating on, and
the you know, the warps and everything,
and that's a lot of those are kind of
hardware controlled, so um you don't
even you know, see. Yeah.
So,
>> [snorts]
>> PTX code is generated by the compiler,
not something that you would normally
go write in.
It looks like it's assembly code.
Yeah, so the question is, do
uh is PTX this is generated by the
compiler? So, there are people who do
write PTX. Um if you really, you know,
think you're better than uh the
compiler. Um
And I I think, you know, the NVIDIA
compilers are generally pretty mature,
but some other, you know, accelerators
that are less developed, I think, you
know, sometimes you just have to reach
in and actually hand-hold a bit more.
But generally, yeah, you
shouldn't um
need to do that. Yeah.
So, when I look at the PTX, so I
when a warp will get scheduled onto an
SM,
I'll get to that TF.load, and it's
almost like a CPU trap call, where like
I'm just waiting for like, you know,
some
you know, something to happen, and like
now I'm just I am twiddling my thumbs,
so some other warp will get scheduled
over me, and then they will do
operations. Now that the TF.load is
done, then I'll reschedule that warp,
and then I'll continue on. Is that kind
of Yeah, that's that's right. So, just
to repeat the the the question
um or the comment. Um so, if you look at
this this Triton code,
um these statements like the uh this
load is going to block for some number
of cycles. And then so, this is running
on some thread on some warp on some SM.
And remember the SM is running multiple
warps at the same time. So, um
you know, when you get to that point, it
can just like, you know,
find another warp to run. And then when
this is done, the warp scheduler comes
back and um takes over.
Why would
four warps be
So, um Uh I'm sorry.
Why would there be four warps in the
same kernel on each SM if four warps are
scheduled
Yeah, so what the question is, why four
warp schedulers? I don't know exactly
the reason behind that.
Okay, so now let's go through some other
examples. Maybe just as a kind of a
quick preview. We're going to do three
more examples. Gelu Gelu is this kind of
the simplest
uh you know, form, even though the the
computation is kind of like, you know,
has a lot of messiness. It's just
element-wise, so conceptually in the
context of um this this lecture is
actually very simple.
Um now we're going to look at softmax,
where now uh you're going to have to do
reduction.
Um but in this case, we're going to
think about the case where row fits on a
block, and then we're going to uh
consider the case where row doesn't fit
on a block, and then we're going to do
go up to matmul.
And then hopefully by that point, you'll
have all the ingredients that you need
to uh do the assignment and implement
flash attention.
Okay.
So,
um so far we looked at element-wise
operations. Um
now let's think about other operations
that aggregate over multiple uh values.
So, remember what the softmax does.
Um
It it's ex- takes a let's just think
uh as a matrix. You exponentiate
and normalize each row of a matrix.
Okay, so this is used in attention, it's
used in, you know, generating
probability output um probabilities. Uh
generally a good good thing to do.
Um
So, let's just start with a naive
implementation, um
and just keep track of what's what's
happening. So, here I'm defining this
tensor, and um
here's the naive implementation.
Um
Actually, I think this is
it's on assignment one.
Um
Okay, anyway. So, uh here I have a M by
N matrix, and so I need to for every row
uh
you know, compute the
you know, I'm going to compute the max
of each row,
and this is for numerical stability. I'm
going to subtract off the max,
um
and then I'm going to, you know,
exponentiate
element-wise, and I'm going to um sum
and compute the normalization constant
for every
um
every row, and I'm going to divide.
Um
and then that's it.
Okay.
So, um
so if you count the number of reads and
writes, remember this is just plain
PyTorch. So, this is a different kernel,
this is a different kernel and unless
you call a torch that compile, these are
going to be different, you know,
operations and each operation is going
to read and write, read and write from
HBM.
Okay, so you have, you know, five uh MN
you know, reads, three MN writes,
um
and in principle
you should really only have
you know,
uh much fewer.
Okay, so this is uh you know, a piece of
code kind of makes sense. Everyone
should be familiar with what a softmax
is doing.
Okay.
So, let's uh let's write now the the
Triton kernel.
Um and
you know, in some sense the the
the form is going to be very similar.
Just like in a GELU, right? Once you do
the scaffolding, the core computation
looks very much like the naive uh
version.
Um so what we're going to do is we're
going to um say each row is a block.
Okay? And why do I make each row a
block?
Well, because now remember each row I
have to normalize and sum. So, it's not
element-wise. Softmax is not
element-wise, but it is sort of sort of
row-wise. So, the blocks don't interact.
Um so, they don't need and the blocks
don't have, you know, shared memory, so
that's that's fine.
A There's no shared memory across
blocks. Um so then within each row, I'm
just going to do some stuff.
Okay, so let's see what happens. Um
so again, I'm going to in Python, I'm
going to allocate my output tensor. Um I
have this M by N, you know, matrix.
Um
I'm going to
define the block size as
uh
you know, basically the number of
columns. Um you know, go to the next
power of two for good luck. Um and then
the number of blocks is just uh um the
number of rows.
Okay, and then I'm going to call this uh
kernel.
So, how many blocks are there?
M, right? One for each row.
And each block I'm going to pass the the
input pointer, the output pointer.
Um and then I'm going to
also uh pass these, you know, uh
you know, strides which tell me um how
how far to move down.
Um okay, so
Okay, let me actually go and show you
the softmax
kernel. Okay.
Um okay, so what does this uh look like
here?
Um
so
I wake up. I'm on a particular row.
Okay? And this is going to give me the
all the columns from zero to the number
of block size, which you know, I'm
assuming that's all the the columns. Um
I'm going to
um
you know, uh read. So, so basically I
need to figure out which
um where to read from memory and that's
going to be the start of my data
plus the you know, which row and the row
stride basically gives me, you know, uh
every row
is is basically this is the number of
columns um essentially. It's going to
get tell me where how far to go down.
Um and then this is X pointers is
basically the addresses of all the data
I need to load. I load them up. Um
and here I do this thing where if it's
uh you know, if it's masked out, then I,
you know, put minus infinity because I
know those are that's going to be kind
of the the equivalent of a a a zero for
the soft softmax operation.
And then this part is essentially the
same as the naive uh softmax. I'm just
going to compute the max, subtract it
off, exponentiate, sum, and divide.
And then I write it back.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, so this is the version where each
block can just uh span the entire row.
So, yeah, this is sort of the and you
you can see that
um
Triton makes this very easy, right?
Because this is as if you were just
normal writing normal PyTorch code.
So, if everything fits in a block, you
basically the the the thing is the thing
is if you can fit anything through a
block, you can just like write normal
PyTorch almost.
Yeah. Um what if my uh number of columns
and number of rows are uh
bigger than block size?
Yeah, so we'll get to that. Now, if the
number of columns, rows, in general,
it's going to be much larger than that
block size, so we'll come back to that.
Yeah. So, if you wanted to do like a
softmax like
Um so, the question is if you wanted to
softmax by column, um I think that
should be fine because here we're
tracking these pointers, right? So, the
pointers are can be anything and here
I've um basically I think all you would
have to do is change the stride uh here.
Um to basically access the the columns.
Actually, it would be here. The column
offsets, you would just make um like the
multiply this by like the row stride, I
think.
Okay, let's let's move on.
All right, so um
now
you know, warming up to the mammal,
suppose that your row doesn't fit into a
block.
Okay, so what do you do in this case?
So, for example, if you have, let's say,
a a row that's uh 400 4,000 columns, but
the block size is only 1,024.
So, you can't cons
uh you know, you have to do something
here.
So, here's the strategy. We're going to
break up the row into tiles.
So, in this case, there's going to be
four tiles
and each thread is going to iterate over
the tiles and accumulate a sum.
And then finally at the end,
um we're going to do the the kind of the
uh reduction.
Um
uh by
you know, uh summing everything that
each thread produced. So, I'll I'll show
you an example of this. And now I'm I'm
sort of switching from softmax to row
sum
um because it's just easier to think
about.
Okay. So, um
So, here Okay, well, this is not very
interesting. The built-in row sum does
uh what you would expect. Um So, the row
sum operation just basically takes
um a a matrix and then computes uh the
sum of each row. Okay? So, just no
surprises there.
Um Okay, so conceptually what we're
going to do here is as follows. Okay, so
each block is still in charge of one
row. So, that part hasn't changed. So,
suppose I'm block one, row one.
I wake up and what do I do?
I'm going to remember now there's tiles
and suppose tile zero is columns zero
through three, tile one is columns four
through seven, call uh and then tile two
is columns eight through 11.
Okay, so what I'm going to do here is
that
I'm going to iterate now. So, first I
basically process
uh this um all the threads. Basically,
each thread keeps a kind of accumulator
and and processes the first tile and
it's going to move on to the next tile
and it's going to add the the current
element to the accumulator. So, here I'm
um putting 3 1 4 1 and then the the
second loop uh iteration, I'm going to
add five to this, I get eight. I add
nine to this, I get 10, two to four, um
and six to one, right? So, each of these
four threads is going to be kind of
accumulating um its own thing.
And then at the end, you know, I do
another for tile two, um I add five and
three to their respective accumulators.
So, at the end of the day, I have this
um you know, a vector of accumulators
and then
that is actually uh you know, that I can
just like sum up.
Okay, so let's see what the code looks
like here. Um
so I'm just going to call the the row
sum kernel and uh
let's see.
Okay, so here's what it looks like. So,
wake up. I am on a particular row
and um
and this is what one row looks like.
There's one tile, a second tile, a third
tile, and so on. So, N is the number of
um elements of that row and block size
is the
uh
um size of this uh this tile.
Okay? So, remember block size is the
number of threads. I'm processing more
data than the larger than the block
size. I just have to do it iteratively
now.
So, uh I'm going to loop over all of the
tiles. So, start is going to go from
zero to block size, to two times block
size, and so on and so forth.
So, each um time I'm, you know, jumping
across, I
I am doing
uh you know, calls uh, basically get
the,
um,
the the offsets
at the particular tile.
Um,
and then I'm going to load
the data
from HBM
and I'm going to add it to the
accumulation. So, this accumulation is
going to be, um, either in registers or,
uh, shared memory.
Okay?
And then finally after I loop over all
the tiles, I process a whole row, I get
basically uh, for every thread I have a
cumulator of what that the thread has
picked up and I can do just do a sum
to get a scalar and I write it out.
Okay? So, this is a little bit more
complicated than before because now we
have a for loop within a thread and this
is, uh, necessary when your data doesn't
fit within a block.
Yeah.
Yeah, so the question is, I think, if
you can control where the cumulator
there resides. At least in this Triton
program, you don't explicitly say and
this is up to the, uh, Triton compiler
to, uh, figure out where to put it.
But in general, if the block size is
large enough, it has to go in shared,
uh, shared memory.
Okay.
All right. Does this, uh, kind of make
sense? So,
you know, you it might
you know, just just to, I think,
make sure people on the same page.
Remember in uh, gelu, we also split a
row into a bunch of, um, pieces, but
those were blocks, right? And so, each
of those pieces was a block that was
processed independently. These are not
blocks. These are tiles.
The block corresponds to this whole, uh,
row.
And and has to basically process all the
tiles and so, this is where it starts to
not look like PyTorch because, uh,
you're not able to process all your data
in one nice kind of
not everything fits into shared memory.
Yeah.
Yeah, I let's say uh, the cumulator is
stored in shared memory.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right. So, um,
let's now maybe go on to our finale,
which is matmul.
Okay? So, matmul of of course is the
bread and butter of deep learning. It's
been optimized to death, um,
and, um, and it's, you know, in some
sense, uh, very,
uh,
you know, fundamental operation. So, you
take two matrices, you multiply them.
I'm going to add a little bit of a twist
here. Um, I'm going to do a matmul
followed by a relu just because just for
kicks.
Okay?
Um, and this is, well, this happens,
right? Because if you have, uh, you
know, one linear layer, it's a matmul
and then you apply, uh, a relu
activation. So, this is not like
completely out of nowhere.
Um, but I'll show you later why I I I
did this.
Okay, so how do you build a matmul
kernel?
All right. So,
here's the naive approach.
Okay, so here's my, uh, let's say, a
matrix. I'm multiplying A times, uh, B
and I'm trying to write out, uh, the
matrix C.
And A is M by K, uh, B is K by N, so C
is M by N.
Okay?
So, what I'm going to do is I'm going to
fix an, uh,
a
a one of these elements. Let's say M
equals 1, N equals 2. Okay? So, I'm
processing Actually, let's do M equals
1, uh, N equals 1. So, I'm doing C5.
And then basically for every K,
I'm going So, I'm going to, um,
uh,
yeah, I'm going to iterate over over the
the K, the rows of A and the columns of
B.
I'm going to read from HBM. I'm going to
multiply them, accumulate that and at
the end, I'm going to write out to, uh,
this this element.
So, that is a valid matmul kernel.
Okay?
So, what's wrong with that?
It's correct, but, you know, if you look
at how many reads and writes it's doing,
uh, this is not good, right? So, um,
basically for every M and N and K, I
have to read from HBM. So, it's on the
order of M times K times N reads.
Uh, number of writes, I mean, it doesn't
matter, but this is a bottleneck, right?
And, um, if you remember from the the
second lecture, if you look at the
number of, um, operations you're doing
divided by the number of bytes that were
transferred, that's the arithmetic
intensity, which you want to be high.
So, the number of operations is M times
K times N
order, um, and then the number of reads
is also the same, so arithmetic
intensity is a constant, which is, uh,
not good.
Okay, so if you look carefully, you
know, you notice that there is a lot of
redundant reads. So, imagine computing
C4.
Um, you needed to read A4, A5 and A6 and
if you compute C5, you're going to have
to read those over again as well.
So,
um,
so if you can just read those once, then
you really save on reads and that's
that's great. So, let's try to use, uh,
shared memory to do that.
So, here's the idealized approach.
I'm going to load all of A and B into
shared memory
and then I'm going to just compute C.
So, if I can do that, then I get, um,
now I don't have this cubic number of
reads, I only get quadratic number of
reads,
um, which means I get the arithmetic
intensity of order N,
um, which in the second lecture I sort
of, um,
you know, said was a I kind of ideal
thing you could hope for.
Okay, so this if you can do that, that's
that's great because you basically
there's no redundant reads. You read
everything once into shared memory, you
do the computation and you write it
back.
Okay, but what's the problem with this
idealized approach?
Uh, the problem is that A and B are
usually too large to fit into shared
memory.
Right?
So, so then what do you have to do now?
Okay, so the idea here is this, you
know, very classic idea of tiling.
And the idea basically is to, well, fit
as much you can to shared memory as you
can, essentially.
So, in some sense, it's it's going to be
look like the naive It's going to
globally look like the naive approach,
but locally look like the idealized
approach is the way to, you know, think
about it.
Um, so here's the, you know, the
picture. Um,
uh, I think Tatsuo showed this as well.
So, what we're going to do is we're
going to take this matrix C
and instead of the Remember the naive
approach just said for every element,
I'm going to do compute it. But now I'm
just going to say for every tile,
um, I'm going to do it. So, I break it
up into tiles.
Um, and each of these tiles is going to
be a thread block.
I'm going to have a bunch of threads
that is responsible to for computing
this.
Now, a different tile is going to be
computed, you know, completely
separately by another, uh, thread block.
Okay, so I'm going to, you know, imagine
I'm in Triton, I'm a
I wake up, I'm I'm looking at this
thread block. So, what do I have to do?
Well, in some sense, it's the same as
the, you know, naive approach where for
every, um,
you know, row tile of A, I'm going to go
scan across the rows and for every
column tile of B,
I'm going to load the the corresponding
tile A and the corresponding, uh, so say
I'm here and the corresponding tile from
B into shared memory.
I'm going to multiply these two together
and
um, and that's going to be, you know,
uh,
you know, like the kind of the idealized
approach and I'm going to accumulate
that
um, in the partial sum and this is all
sitting in shared memory. And then after
I finish all the the sweep of the row
and the column here, then I can finally
write this output tile to HBM.
Okay? So, that's,
you know, the conceptually what's
happening.
Um, and then the arithmetic intensity
here now goes up to order tile size.
So, you can generally not reach order N
because that would require you to fit
everything into shared memory, but, you
know, if your tiles are big, then
that's, you know, still not too bad.
Okay, so just as kind of a bonus, um,
you know, while you're doing all writing
a kernel for this anyway,
um, sometimes if you want to apply an
element-wise activation function,
um, it's very easy to just like put it
on at the end. And this is, you know,
kernel fusion. Okay, so very quickly the
implementation here, um,
so
oops.
Okay, so, um, just as kind of a reminder
about strides since that's just going to
show up. So,
a tensor is, um, you know,
multi-dimensional array,
but in memory, it's linearized and
strides of a tensor tells you basically
how to map from a multi-dimensional
index such as a row uh, a comma column
into an actual index. And basically,
what you do is multiply the row by the
stride the plus the column by the stride
of the column.
Okay, so in this case,
um every time you go advance to the next
row, you go four positions in your
memory. And every time you advance a
column, you go one.
In the if it were a transpose, it would
be the flipped.
Okay, so what does this
a kernel uh look like here?
Um
So, there's um
Okay, so the launch is not interesting.
Um so, you wake up and you are on tile M
and N. So, it's like, "Okay, I'm
responsible for computing um the C
uh matrix, but for the M / uh comma N
tile."
Um there's a bunch of like index
manipulation, which um you can kind of
I'll just gloss through, but it's it's
it's straightforward, but a little bit.
Um
you know, just have to
track the the indices. So, this
basically tells you which rows
of A the matrix A I'm looking at, which
rows of uh oh sorry, which columns of B
I'm looking at, and then this is just
the numbers one through one through K.
Um then I going to get the the pointers
into A and B at my tile location.
Um and then I'm going to set up this
accumulator matrix. This is going to be
in shared memory.
Um this is M by N. And then this is
going to look kind of like the uh row
reduction, right? You have this
uh um sum over all of the the tiles, but
instead of just going across the the
tiles, I'm now going across the row
tiles and also simultaneously down the
column tiles of B.
I load A the small matrix, I load B the
small uh B tile, and then I perform this
dot. So, remember, whenever things are
in shared memory, things look like
PyTorch, and I can just say say "Matmul
it." And you know, it'll do the do the
thing.
And then
and then
uh and then I advance to the next row
tile of A and the next column tile of B.
Um and this is like you know, just
uh the bonus is that if I wanted to
apply element-wise non-linearity, I
might as well, you know, do that here.
Uh before I write it out to HBM, I can
do some any sort of operation on it. And
then the finally, I just write it out.
Okay.
So, there's some sort of indices that
you have to pay attention to, but
hopefully the um form of the algorithm
is is clear.
Okay.
Any questions about that?
All right, maybe I'll just summarize,
and you can ask me later. So,
today we talked about the there's a
programming model, which is you know,
you're talking about um either PyTorch
or Triton or PTX. Even this is um the
you know, what the kind of programmer
can control.
Right? And even PTX, you can write PTX,
and you can control every, you know,
specialize however you want.
Um but this is not the full picture,
because the reality is that your
code has to run on hardware, and there's
only a finite number of SMs, a finite
number of banks, and and you know,
sizing of memory and registers all are
finite. So, you come in with your big
matrix and transformer, and you want to
you it has to kind of fit in with the
constraints of um the the hardware.
Um so, that's why, you know,
benchmarking and profiling are really
important to understand how the
messiness of the hardware
um translates to, you know, performance.
Um we talked about Triton, which is I
think a pretty nice neat language to
think about uh thread blocks. Hopefully,
by now you can appreciate that um things
are easier to think about thread blocks
than individual threads, because you
don't have to think about explicitly
synchronizing threads or doing shared
memory.
And the way to think about it is that
you figure out you have your
computation, you break it down into
these thread blocks, where you just need
to read from shared memory, do some
stuff, and write it back into HBM.
And then we saw some examples of
increasing uh difficulty. Element-wise
is the easiest, and then reduction over
a row,
um reduction where the it doesn't uh fit
into a row, and that's sort of we
introduced kind of the baby tiling, and
then Matmul is the kind of the the the
canonical example, where you actually do
tiling.
Okay, so that's all I'm going to say
about how to program a single GPU. Next
time, we're going to go to more GPU and
talk about um multi-GPU programming. Um
yeah, question. Uh so, if I'm able to
write my own kernels, what are the
alternatives that I have to Triton, and
what are the range of my choices that I
have? Like how close can I get to the
optimal performance?
Uh so, the question is uh what are
alternatives to to Triton? Um
So,
you know, there's a trade-off between
every language has sort of inductive
bias, right? That makes certain things
easier and certain things harder.
So, most of what we do, Triton was
built, you know, by people who, you
know, train transformers. So,
anything involving uh transformers, I
think it's going to be relatively
um
you know, easy there. Um of course, in
the extreme, you can always go to PTX
and uh write that, but you know,
wouldn't advise that as a first step.
There are a bunch of other uh language
uh sort of libraries. There's you know,
ThunderKittens, there's uh you know,
cute you know, various DSLs that allow
you to give you
you know, they're not necessarily
necessarily comparable uh either up or
down the stack, they just give you
different um you know, characteristics.
Yeah. When you have a high-dimensional
tensor,
uh you know,
multiplications or a high-dimensional
tensor
processing,
uh what is the best approach? Is there
is there like what I'm thinking is can I
load
unload the whole tensor
both of the tensors on you know, bunch
of threads or thread blocks on my
GPU at the same time and compute them,
or would it be better to
sort of, you know, take each
element, just what we did here, right?
For the particular particular component
of of my tensor, then process it, and
then write it back into HBM?
Yeah, so the briefly the question, and
we should probably wrap up, is um
is it better to kind of read all at once
or maybe process individual elements at
um a time. Um I think it's hard to
answer this in the abstract. It kind of
depends on the nature of the
computation. Um
uh maybe I we can talk offline about
that.
Okay. All right, see you next time.